[Musique]
étrangers
les gens parlent enfin de vous
savez
euh
la violence contre les femmes
et à quel point vous savez qu'elle augmente, ils
parlent plus de vous connaissez la
culture du viol dont ils parlent de la façon dont le
blâme de la victime doit être  stop
[Music]
on m'a fait sentir que j'avais fait
quelque chose de mal, c'est pourquoi j'ai obtenu ce que
je méritais
et étant une femme dans cette société, je
ne devrais pas
exiger justice et ce n'était pas bien
pour moi de sortir et de demander  justice,
il y a beaucoup de lois qui doivent être
mises en œuvre, nous devons faire
adopter le projet de loi sur la violence domestique, nous devons
vous faire connaître plus de lois sur le viol, euh, vous
savez des procès plus rapides pour les victimes, donc
dans l'ensemble, euh, vous savez que la structure policière
doit  être d'une manière qui, vous le savez,
soutient les victimes,
leur collecte de preuves doit être
meilleure, il y a beaucoup de choses qui
doivent me changer